so wait i was told that this was your
first trip away from your kids in a year
yeah is that how are you do you need um
help or anything you know i i it's hard
it's a lot of anticipatory dread like
the week before i go i have crazy
migraines and
i mean i'm just i i it's like it's
really really hard and then all of a
sudden i'm gone i'm sitting on the plane
and i have six uninterrupted hours and
you crochet
and like just do nothing or
or all the things i want to do all the
time but i never do i watched ocean's
11.
i listened to kelly clarkson congrat
good taste good yes i know no that's
that's awesome i was going to say i have
that dread it's it is anticipatory
because you're you're like oh my god
something's going to happen to them i'm
not going to be here like i start
dreading everything and then i get on
the plane i'm like this is amazing it is
and it's sad we're i'm heartbroken like
i was in contact with him the whole
flight on wi-fi but i i and there's no
guilt you know we shouldn't have guilt
when we like finally have time for
ourselves and i had a margarita yeah
like
i don't know one yeah five o'clock
somewhere exactly
great yeah um i love that for you and i
actually do appreciate it and know what
you're talking about it's very nice
[Music]